we all know that every queen needs a
decked out castle
so today we're gonna hook up a very
worthy mama
with some design by drew
please meet maria cook my name is maria
cook
in september of 2020 my father and my
mom
decided to finally retire back in costa
rica
unfortunately they flew out and within
10 days my dad had passed away
from kobe they all tell you that you go
through waves with grief and that's
pretty much what happened to me
once i was able to book a vaccine for my
mom
and my husband i saw how difficult it
was
to do that so i put my services for
volunteering out there
and became a member of a facebook group
called
new jersey vaccine info i made a post
and i said here is my dad i lost
him i don't want any family to have to
lose someone else
so in honor of him i want to help people
trying to find an appointment
get those vaccines i have been able to
book
100 and 200 vaccines so far for seniors
i believe that my dad is looking down
and saying
[Music]
i i raised her right and
sorry i hope that he's proud
that i turned something negative into
something positive
i have been married to my husband for
almost 16 years
we have two beautiful children and the
opportunity
came finally for us to be able to
buy a new home unfortunately the kids
have absolutely taken over
i feel that i don't have a little bit of
the house that would be just for me
i think that living room will be perfect
for that but
i spend so much time helping others that
i honestly don't have time to create my
own space
i would love for drew to help me i think
that i could learn a lot from her and i
can learn a lot from what she can
show me this living room could have so
much potential i just really do not know
what to do with that space
oh we know what to do so
we told maria she was coming to our
offices to meet one of our producers but
i had something else in mind because i
always do take a look
[Music]
hi hi oh my god it's you
hi maria hi drew
oh my god so nice to meet you
i love what you've done with your
vaccine program too
will you tell me about that i lost my
dad on october of 2020
so sorry thank you it was very tough i
had to make sure that my mom was
vaccinated
and the system is very difficult to
navigate and i just want to make sure
that nobody
goes through what my family has been
through
well i am glad that you are the pillar
of strength in your family
i hear that your kids have basically
like taken over your living room oh god
yes
yeah it's like kids headquarters is
just toys everywhere so we've teamed up
with sherwin williams
to give your living room a makeover what
are you serious
i really can't think of anyone who's
more deserving of this
and i live for design and i love
to make over people's faces so we're
going to
redo your living room is that okay i'm
smiling
we're going to take the sherwin-williams
color snap color id
quiz i'm going to scroll through some
couches and you're going to tell me
which one you're liking
i like the smoky gray great i think
that's a really smart choice
okay imagine you sat down what are you
guys going to watch together
action and adventure reality show
rom-com nothing i prefer a book
i prefer action and adventure
see what kind of person you are maria
it's time to reveal your color id you're
a trendsetter
if you were to pick a color from the
color
blocks and palettes what would you
choose
i do like that alpaca i think that that
is a perfect segue for you to meet macau
okay who is my design partner in this
macau
well hello we are ready to get to work
we are with and for maria and we mean
business i feel good about this
do you feel confident about it i am so
excited
now our client macau was gravitating
towards
maybe a neutral color palette but with
pops of
color i love you already and i just met
you i'm down for the challenge i'm
excited
so excited okay maria we know what to do
we're gonna go to work
and thank you for just everything you're
doing for everybody else
and we're so excited to give back to you
okay so after surprising maria we all
got to work
and we took maria's color id palette
and brainstormed the perfect furniture
lighting and
fixtures that would complement her trend
setting personality and provide the
comfort
and adult space that she needed and
i hope that it all came together
[Music]
perfectly